en colombia el cambio también llega a la
cúpula de la seguridad de la defensa el
viernes el presidente gustavo petro
presentó a las nuevas altas esferas de
las fuerzas armadas y la policía
planteando como objetivo que éstas
tengan un enfoque claro en la protección
y defensa de los derechos humanos y en
términos de garantizar
paz de garantizar la disminución de la
violencia
de la criminalidad
de garantizar el incremento sustancial
del respeto a los derechos humanos y las
libertades ciudadanas como en toda
democracia debe ser las cabezas de la
defensa y la seguridad estarán
comandadas por elder giraldo que
dirigirá a las fuerzas militares jose
joaquin a mezquita que estará al mando
del estado mayor conjunto luis mauricio
ospina nuevo comandante del ejército
henrry sanabria nuevo director de la
policía y jacqueline navarro
subdirectora de la institución y segunda
mujer en asumir este rol luís carlos
córdoba que comandará la fuerza aérea y
francisco cubides nuevo comandante de la
armada colombiana que tiene que dar un
cambio de doctrina en el en el tema
militar y policial de colombia razón por
la cual lo segundo que se va a hacer es
sacar a la policía del ministerio de
defensa y crear un ministerio de la paz
la seguridad y la convivencia ministerio
propio al devastar la policía y lo
segundo lentamente en la formación de
las personalidades en que se construye
una doctrina donde haya un respeto por
los derechos humanos con la designación
de la cúpula militar más de 30 generales
se verán obligados a dejar la
institución porque la ley dice que un
jefe no puede llevar menos tiempo en la
carrera que sus subordinados
de este modo echa a andar la estrategia
defensiva del primero de izquierda del
país andino que busca desmarcarse de
instituciones salpicadas por escándalos
y actos de violencia contra la población
civil los nuevos altos mandos tienen
formación administrativa y en derechos
humanos pero sobre todo no cargan con
investigaciones judiciales en su contra
un requisito imprescindible para el
nuevo mandatario